hey what's up to YouTube welcome to
another HD tutorial and in this video
I'll be showing you how to remove
unwanted background noise from your
videos and from your audio using two
programs okay the first one I'm going to
use is audacity you've probably watched
my audacity tutorial already but if you
haven't go check it out just showing you
guys how do you download audacity and a
brief intro so we're gonna do is remove
the background noise and Odyssey so I
have a sample clip here and it has a
little bit of background noise in here
just a little bit of white noise that I
might want to get rid of especially in
this ending part right here what I'm
going to do is select a part just by
clicking and dragging and letting go
when I'm done and this is the part I've
selected with the white noise in it so
I've intentionally paused at the end of
my speaking to give it a chance to
realize that that's white noise now that
I've selected I'm going to go to effect
and go down to noise removal click it
and you'll have to go step one is to
click select a few seconds of just noise
so i'd acity knows what to filter up
then click get noise profile so we're
gonna we already selected it we selected
get noise profile and then we're going
to select the entire track just by
clicking and dragging over the entire
thing and we go to effect and we go down
to noise removal again and this is where
we select all the audio which we already
did and choose how much noise you want
filtered out so I'm gonna a good rule of
thumb is to drag it all the way to less
if to preview it and you obviously won't
hear the preview but you're going to hit
the I owe you but out yeah we hit the
preview button and you realize on if you
want more or less audio taken out I'll
drag it to about where I think it's done
and after you've heard the preview again
hit remove noise and the noise is
already completely removed so if you
were to play it back you might not hear
it but it actually is completely gone on
all your all your background noise is
good so you'll be able to focus exactly
on my audio and I'm going to try to use
it for this video too so that's how you
do it in audacity and stay tuned for a
lot more audacity tutorials to come so
let's open the second way which is to
actually do with the camera file in
Camtasia Studio 6
so we're going to do is import media and
we're just going to import any random
video here I'll just go into my videos I
have a few videos I'll import obviously
an introduction video isn't a great idea
because it has music in it but again if
you were to import a camera file with
you speaking you would want to do this
kind of thing so I'll just drag your
file to the timeline it has to be on the
timeline before you do anything with it
and you obviously choose your preset I'm
gonna choose my HD preset and if you do
want to know how to use that or make
that HD preset just go ahead and watch
the video it's very good so once you
have this we're going to select where we
want to do the noise removal so I'm
going to zoom in here and say there's a
part I don't want to move it into the in
the introduction but after the
introduction when I'm speaking I'm gonna
highlight that part or I'm actually
speaking and this is the part where I
want to remove noise so we're going to
go up here to the Edit tab and we're
going to go to audio enhancements and
while this region down here is still
selected we're going to hit man we're
going to go automatically try to detect
noise on the timeline and just hit
remove noise and there you go it's
finished removing the noise from the
timeline so now when you do play it back
and by the way the region that's
selected afterward is a part where it's
identified you're actually you have
white noise so you can go ahead and play
it back in just make sure you know that
that's the way you like it now if you
don't like that you can obviously go
ahead and hit the restore noise button
and restore all the noise that was there
before and when you're done hit OK and
your audio has been fixed so that's how
you fix noise background noise white
noise computer running noise in the
background and two different programs
Camtasia Studio 6 obviously audacity so
if you do like this tutorial go ahead
and subscribe there are a lot more
tutorials to come as well as my previous
videos which you should probably check
out and thanks for watching this one
peace
you